back so it's like an unglorious time of
the day to listen to me talking about
event-driven architecture there is going
to be a lot of drawings and diagrams
because this is an architecture talk so
if I fall asleep on my own talk can you
please wake me up because I'm still a
little bit woozy with my jet lag and all
I have to cross three different time
zones and yeah so I'm a bit sleepy I
apologize already but I'm gonna try to
you know wake you up a little bit so
today we're going to talk about yeah
event driven architecture in Azure and
there are a couple of things that I want
to focus on this is a little bit of a
fundamental session so I want to talk
about some of the basic concepts around
event driven architecture and for
example we want to focus on the
different nuances that we come across
when we are designing event-driven
applications because there's a lot you
know it gets kind of confusing sometimes
I'm a developer and I get very confused
with the different terminologies around
event driven and then we're going to
look at the different Azure services
that we can use to implement this in in
Practical and there's a little bit of
demo in the end but like I said because
this is an architecture session so I
have mostly drawings and diagrams and
we're going to go through that together
and towards the end let's look at the
different pitfalls that we can encounter
some of the challenges that
um that we need to be be careful about
when we're designing event-driven
applications
this is my first time on NDC stage and I
arrived in Sydney like a week ago
already and totally having fun so I hope
you guys have fun with me a little bit
you know
have a little bit of energy even though
this is such a heavy architecture talk
um just a little bit introduction about
myself my name is marila di matulak it's
venovic now and I am a software
architect and I've been in this industry
for far too long like
really long
um I'm not going to reveal how long but
recently I am obsessed with building
Cloud native apps and app modernization
and I've always been passionate about
you know patterns the main driven design
because I also think that really good
architecture is is really important
especially in in developer Wellness I'm
also very passionate about developer
Wellness development developer happiness
because you know all of these things
would burn out we want to avoid that and
I believe that really good architecture
is one of the best way to avoid
developer burnout I'm also very active
in Tech communities I'm a founder of a
not-for-profit organization called
ulup.org and we try to get some of this
underserved kids certified in cloud data
and Technology like 19 years old getting
certified I'm not I don't feed it
and yeah I'm an Azure MVP and I'm also
an entrepreneur I have my own company
crazy enough to start my own company six
years ago it's a cloud native company
we're based in Copenhagen and Manila
it's called the wise
I always want to start my talk with um
with the why why do I want to talk about
event-driven architecture why am I
interested with event-driven
architecture because if you think about
it it's like I'm I'm a fan of stories I
read a lot of stories I write stories I
listen to stories and if you think about
it software development is just you know
automating the stories of Our Lives
but we're automating the kind of like
not significant stories of our life like
going shopping so so that we have more
time to leave out the stories that
really that we really enjoy you know
like creating art we shouldn't automate
that
um but you know when we design software
based on the principle of domain driven
design we want to design software that
kind of
um easy to understand because it's so
close and it's so related to our
everyday lives to our stories and this
is where um the terminology is event
driven design and the patterns in event
driven design really resonate with me
because it really represents our
everyday life our stories the stories of
our existence as humans
we value events we remember events we
celebrate events we react to events
every time something happens a fact
happens we react to it so we should also
try to model our software which is the
automation of our stories based on the
same principles
but there's another reason why I'm very
keen with event-driven architecture it's
because there is a fundamental issue
with the way we are creating our
software now
so we talk about stories right but the
way we are creating our software
application now where we are trying to
just
overwrite what's on our record the
record of our facts you know we have
mutable databases whenever we try to
overwrite the facts in our databases
that's a very typical software
architecture pattern it's like we're
skewing our stories
it's like reading the records in the
database is like reading a fairy tale
where you say
Once Upon a Time the princess met the
prince and they live happily ever after
it's like the rest of the facts are gone
with the traditional way of our software
development and this is again where some
patterns in an event-driven application
can really help us straighten out the
story for us to record every single fact
that led us to the current state of our
application
so that's my why I want to solve that
story like this is our plan and we have
a lot of stories facts happening all the
time one of my favorite stories is the
story of my kids just to illustrate how
we design software nowadays so these are
my kids this is my son rain and this is
my daughter Rayla and they moved with me
to Denmark about a couple of years ago
and they are enrolled in a school called
bir que Royal gymnation it's with the uh
it's like it's hard to pronounce big
local origination it's like having a
potato in your mouth so um they're
enrolled there and actually this year my
son just graduated
yay I have a
full adult son but I know it's hard to
believe I can't believe it myself but
don't tell him that oh this is live he's
watching anyways
um so if I look in his school records if
I look in the school system I'm gonna
pull out his record his profile profile
and he's just gonna say
graduated
but before that happened he was also
applying or accepted or registered and
enrolled so but I don't see that anymore
it's gone we well-meaning developers
have over overridden and how many times
have we developed software like this
maybe we have some audit log but that
doesn't give us the full picture and the
audit log is not really meant for us to
replay the state of the system and look
at it in different time zones
so we want to change that with a better
pattern
so what is event-driven architecture
essentially you know in a nutshell it's
an architectural style that relies on
events events are simple you know
statement of facts something that has
already happened and relying that to
have event processors that can execute
logic asynchronously based on these
events
to be able to execute a workflow or
problem domain so for example in the use
case that I have shown you with the
student enrollment
so maybe there are different steps in
the student enrollment and there are
different processors uh in in the same
workflow but
um you need something to bind this
um decoupled asynchronous processors and
you can use events to be able to trigger
some action
and event-driven architecture is
not new you can use it in different
combinations with other architectural
Styles like you know you can use it in
monolith but it really shines in
distributed applications where you have
decoupled processors and how to make
sure that they don't have a very strong
dependency with each other but they can
still communicate with each other via
events so there a lot of use cases with
event driven architecture it's like I
said it's quite common it's not new so
for example cloud is inherently at least
partly
um event driven like especially with the
side with the cloud native event-driven
Auto scaling so if you're familiar with
kubernetes and cada like you can use
events like as signals to trigger some
logic to be to scale your you know your
infrastructure iot Solutions are also
very much event driven so for example
you know if you have devices in this
room you just ingest a lot of different
data about the current temperature and
you take all these signals to adjust the
temperature in the room so it's also
event driven gaming is also another
use case but Enterprise apps
um how many of you build event-driven
Enterprise apps oh quite a lot good
so it is mix yeah in in in my some of
you probably getting there or looking
into it and like also in my experience
in Enterprise application development
there are still a lot of teams and
developers who want to
Implement event driven but only
partially and some are still very
traditional and doesn't really use
events at all
and I think one of the the reasons why
there's a kind of a block curve or
implementing event driven is it can
easily get complex because of some of
the nuances that we face so I want to go
through some of these nuances so that we
can clarify some of the terminologies
and really for the people who have
experience or a lot of experience with
event-driven application feel free to
contradict to raise your hand and say
that's not right because this is the
point where Architects really are
developers really you know started
pushing their own agenda so no that's
not right so it could happen and it
always happens but let's see
so one of the very basic things
commands versus events
some people get confused some people
understand it right away but the thing
is they're both messages
that use to trigger some sort of an
action but the meaning itself you know
the you know the subtlety in the
language is very different
so commands are you know expressed it
expresses your intention to for an
action to execute so somebody wants
something to happen
that's a command you know it's very
active I want you to do this so in our
use case for student enrollment you can
say register the student
and that's a command whereas an event
also a message that gets passed around
in the system that can also trigger
another action but you trigger the
action because something has happened
so for example in the whole student
enrollment system
after you have completed the student
registration there's an event called
student registered and that can trickle
down to the system and execute more
logic
so there's a difference in the way we
use the verbs another thing with the
command if we compare so command can be
first of all validated
where events are already valid it
already happened it already it's already
a fact so command needs to First
validate before it executes an action
so if it's invalid you throw an error
but if it's valid
then you execute the action and the
action can still fail and succeed so a
failed action is an event that you can
still capture whereas an action that
succeeded or like for example a student
registered or student registration fail
they're both events drawn up from the
same command
so understanding this terminology can
help us really model our workflow our
system and then Implement that in code
so let's look at simple example in code
so this is an example of a very simple
um
very simple command so like I said your
naming convention is always to start
with the verb that's in present tense
register student and it's also just data
so you have some data that that you
require to be able to execute a command
and then somewhere along the way you
probably have a command Handler that
gets triggered to execute an action and
after that action has completed like
maybe you have executed some logic
business logic you call your database or
you did some validation you can publish
the event once you have completed so
event is also just a data it's just
model just the event the data in the
event then nodes the the like what
happened so it explains what happens or
what are the attributes that were
changed so for example when you register
the student after the students
registered then you probably need which
student ID and what program they will
registered to
and in event-driven application you
would also have an event handler the
event processor so once this is
triggered then you can do something and
this sample code I showed is very simple
and it's still in process you're still
not Crossing Network boundaries you're
still not triggering any other
components but this is just a very basic
code
all right
so I hope you guys understand commands
and events very important terminology
so how do we trigger this chain of
command and events and chain and
commands inside our system so now we
start looking at requests
async requests
is sometimes related to event driven but
depends on your implementation it's
probably not event driven yet but a lot
of people refer to just simple
asynchronic synchronous request as event
driven but let's see
so this is very familiar this is a very
simple way of you know designing our
application you have the request
response model and in the here you have
just two components crossing the network
you probably have a UI component fires
up the request to an endpoint the
endpoint processes it and right away
um
deliver the response so a lot of our
apis are built like this but we all know
that this could you know cause some
issues later down the line with
scalability and latency and all that so
you might want to decouple your
components using asynchronous requests
so this is one of the patterns that you
can use for asynchronous requests this
is not the only one so in this
in this pattern you have your UI let's
say again in the student enrollment use
case you have your UI you register the
student you call an endpoint and
immediately you get a reply that we're
processing your request and the endpoint
will enqueue this so that it can be
processed later on by its Handler so
it's like temporal processing so the
queue in the middle takes care of you
know decoupling of the components and as
well as scaling or load balancing or
load leveling so to make sure that the
hand you have enough you know instances
of the Handler that can handle the load
or that you can travel the load so that
you know that you don't kill your
handlers or your your API and then you
have a way to of course if you need to
reply back to your UI component there
are several ways in this particular
pattern you you use a polling pattern
wherein like from the Handler maybe you
save the state along the way of the
database but then you you also provide
provide an end point for the UI to call
to check the status of the long running
process or once that's completed you
also provide a resource endpoint where
your client can also see
the final state of the processing
software the student registration you
will have a two endpoints to look at the
pro where are we in the process of
student registration and at the end
give me the record for registered
students
there are other patterns for this you
can also do request reply where you
don't pull but then the Handler also
sends a message back to the UI of about
the status and what has happened
who thinks this is event driven
some
yes could be
but
a little bit in my book not so much
because we're still pushing or sending a
command
we're still requesting something to
happen nothing has been triggered
because something else has happened
so there's just a little subtle
difference yeah but of course this can
be the starting point for event driven
this an event-driven application is a
mix so it can start from a simple
request and then propagate into events
so
let's look at the patterns for event uh
driven design
there are different topologies that you
can use when
um when designing applications to be
event driven and this is the first one
which is what you call the broker
choreography pattern this is where you
know things are fun and cool but then
they can go wrong and no one has you
know a single responsibility for what's
happening that means all the
participants in this event-driven
workflow needs to be responsible enough
to know what to do when something goes
wrong so if I give you an example let's
say in the student enrollment workflow
first you need to register the student
and after that you automatically enroll
the students in different classes based
on the program so that's a different
bounded context the classes student
test takes care of the Student Records
whereas the class enrollment takes care
of the class domain aggregate like you
know who are the students enroll with
other classes and at the same time at
the end of class enrollment you're going
to find out okay what kind of books do I
want to issue to the students who are
enrolled this class but that books
component or bounded context is you know
it's it's a different team that's
developing that and at the same time
it's a different set of users it's a
bookstore so they're all participants in
the whole student enrollment workflow
um in the choreography choreography
pattern so you have the concept of you
know the event producer which is again
like the Handler that first executed the
student registration and once that's
completed it broadcasts that okay I'm
done with my my job I have registered
the student it uses an event broker
that's the only responsibility of the
event broker is to know who are all the
subscribers for this
particular event
so it just pushes out this notification
so that they can execute their own logic
like for example the class enrollment
and the books
issuing of books
but what happens if something goes wrong
in the class domain for example they
can't enroll the class so technically
the student enrollment isn't completed
well if you don't design your
application well using this pattern then
it's hard right it's hard to do error
handling it can easily go hey where so
there are also other patterns for this
you can emit another event that
something went wrong and then the other
participants can receive that and do
like a compensating transaction pattern
where they try to roll back what they
have done and yeah it's it's it will
work but then it can get very
complicated towards you know if if your
scenario gets a bit more complex but the
good thing about this is because you
don't have a dependency on a single
entity because they're all kind of
independent then it's easily scalable
it's a bit more flexible
so that's a very common pattern and the
next one is what you would call a
mediator pattern or a process manager
so in this case you actually have
like one
entity there one function that sort of
organize all these events and commands
and error handling to be able to
complete the entire workflow to solve
the problem so do you have you know
relatives that kind of if you have
reunions family reunions you always have
one person that just takes care of
everyone make sure that everyone can are
present and attend but they get very
stressed at the end of the reunion so
that's like that's like my sister for me
she calls all my relatives it's like oh
are you coming or not coming oh you're
sick oh you're doing this so she gets
very stressed but things happen you know
it's so much easier with us we don't
have to worry about you know changing
our plans because someone else is doing
it so that's the same with this
particular pattern so you would
typically have yeah what you would call
um a mediator that would also produce
the events and push the events into
different channels and then the
participating components let's say the
class components and the books component
can also still receive this notification
and once they're done they can reply
back to the mediators so the mediator
can continue executing
the workflow
uh so it is
I would say much more organized and safe
and easier for error handling
um but then you start becoming dependent
on one entity that's the trade-off so
that means there's one entity that has
to know it all that has to scale better
so it's not as scalable as the ones
where it's all independent but certainly
a little safer
so for for example I'll give you
something Azure uh you could use
something called Azure functions Azure
durable functions that can orchestrate
all these different activities and can
you know fire up commands receive uh
messages and then fire in other events
and then maybe that particular durable
function can also keep track of the
events pushed out to some service bus to
other components and then it receives
the the message back so once it's
completed
um and in our student enrollment
workflow maybe this is
a student enrollment workflow maybe this
is the best pattern to be able to
complete the student enrollment workflow
we will have a mediator but when do we
use the choreography pattern in
combination I would say that would be
nice to use it like after the entire
end-to-end workflow is completed you can
fire up another event like your
integration event so that you can
announce to the greater system that the
particular workflow is completed so
let's say it's not just you know student
registered class enrolled books issued
but student enrollment completed and
maybe other parts of the system is
interested in that particular event so
that they can execute their actions
again
so you can use it in combination so
single unit of um of of business
workflow of logic may be better with
mediator but then with the larger
integration pattern you can also use or
combine it with
um the choreography pattern
yep
so those are the two now
there's something else
with event-driven architecture so if if
you're very familiar you probably have
come across event streaming and event
sourcing where does this all play out
what's the difference is there a
difference even so I mean it depends on
our use case right so we keep on
extending the event-driven architecture
pattern when do we who uses event
streaming
in their architecture cool and how about
events forcing
how does that go let her know
yeah
um so what is event stream
so again similar
um similar use case but now we're
thinking about
other
other use cases the event stream is very
very good also with ingesting Big Data
large amount of data for particularly
for Analytics so the scenario we had
earlier the messages that were passing
the commands that we're passing are you
know isolated to a single business
workflow
and the simple pattern for choreography
and mediator will suffice but before the
student has actually registered or
classes are enrolled or like mean
details that are actually happening
every second and every minute before we
even get to the point that the student
is registered for example in the UI you
might have the student or the teacher
must have clicked different buttons
first maybe they invoked an error maybe
they switch contacts and page and came
back before you know before everything
was completed so there are like these
small data points that's still relevant
in our story of student enrollment you
might want to catch because you might
want to improve your service you might
want to do analytics on it
so this you know ingestion of
big amounts of data stream is is very is
very good for data for event streaming
and the the concept is that instead of
having an event broker like in the
previous pattern
um you could have what you call an
append Only log so for example your UI
keeps on you know pushing all these
activities user activities in an append
Only log and that log is designed to
push out streams of data and stream is
just an unbounded data set and bounded
meaning it's always growing it's
Timeless
and then it's in order it's immutable
and you can replay the data that's in
the Stream
and your stream processors
consume
this data and maybe they only consume
particular you know events that are
interesting to them so for example if
you have an um stream processor that
wants to isolate all the events related
to errors on the UI so that you can do
some analytics to improve your UI then
you would only listen to that to those
events so you can listen to a particular
topic so maybe you have an event
processor that's interested uh with the
things all the other things that the
user is doing in the browser before they
get to the point of registering and then
you can use that and then do some
aggregation or transformation or maybe
you want to derive some data and and
refresh your read model that is more
suitable for reporting or for for for
for other use cases so you want to
listen to The Stream and process this
stream
so it's slightly different from just
announcing or notifying that a business
process has been completed but this one
is really really and event stream is
really good for that you can implement
it if you need it if you have the
capacity if you understand your use case
and the value from it yes but it's not
necessary that's the same with the
concept of Event Source Event Source is
also
logging a series of events but the
difference is that the inventors when we
use event streaming we're talking about
pushing data
to other external processors whereas
event storming is more internal it's
still in the same bounded context let's
look at the bounded context of a student
yeah so it's just about the student
registration and Event Source just means
that every single event that
um that happened in order to arrive to
the current state of the student will be
persisted in a persistence
infrastructure like a database and it's
going to stay there forever unlike in
event streams the streams actually don't
have to stay forever they can be
retained there's a retention period for
your streams because you know it's real
time it's it's real time your processors
are just um
accumulating and processing all the time
it can go back in time it can choose in
which time window it wants to process
but at some point those logs will be
removed whereas in Event Source
everything that has happened to
particular entity domain entity like the
student is persisted in a database and
what do you use it for so that you can
go through every single fact and arrive
at the current state
so again going back to the story that
we're overriding our mutable records or
databases this is kind of like the
answer for that so instead of overriding
you just record every event that has
transpired and use that and query that
to replay that to be able to arrive at
the current state at any given time you
can go back in a different time and you
will see a different state of the entity
or the Aggregate and at the same time
with with the Event Source
and the the thing that you need to watch
on forward Adventure is of course your
log can really grow so it depends on
your use case you have to
um watch out for that but it's really
also very good for debugging for error
handling for looking at what happened
again it's not something that we have to
apply all the time depends on the use
case it can get complicated but it's
worth looking at so what is the
difference with an event source with a
traditional a traditional log for
example we can do audit logs right but
like I said the logs if if you do audit
logging so this is very good events are
very good for audit logging but if you
do the traditional audit logging and not
even answers it's only like we're
logging just a subset of the information
that we needed not the whole state not
the whole transition of state so for
example in the student registration you
might have something in your audit lab
student status change by who at what
date and that's all you see in the log
whereas in an Event Source you have the
full picture of the current state of the
student at the time something has
changed
all right
who wants to implement Event Source now
no one
me
okay there's one more thing
in the list of nuances
change data capture
so we have just been talking about data
all the time
data persistent in log data persisted as
Event Source in an event store
all of this is just data persistence or
manipulation of data so what is the
difference with our event logs with our
traditional database with our batch
files Etc so to change data capture is
kind of
a current feature of some of the modern
databases nowadays so what it means is
that every time a document if it's an if
it's a document database for example or
a record in an rdbms has been created or
changed or updated or deleted
it fires an event that you can consume
that you can listen to as a component
um so for example let's say Azure Cosmos
DB has the concept of change feed so
every time you manipulate the document
you can listen to the feed you can fire
up an Azure function that binds to the
change feed and do some logic to it and
you can also use like normal.net core
application to use the change feed
processor so that you can go through the
feed and do some action
so yeah certainly we can do this in an
event driven
in our event-driven landscape
but it's like the concept of something
happening in the database and you know
hooking up to it is also not new we also
have the concept of database triggers
before where we write some custom code
because something has happened and we
also have transaction logs in the
database but they were never really
designed for you know chaining commands
and events before like the the
transaction like the audit log is again
meant for
thinking what happened before but it's
not to execute a particular business or
domain domain process
so what what in my book
with the change change data capture it
for me if I use it to execute business
logic based on what happened to a
document or to a database record it
doesn't feel right because it's so much
related to the infrastructure and not to
the business when we walk around
registering a student we don't talk
about oh did you update the database or
maybe you do but it's like it's it's not
close to the real world we're getting
tied up we're getting a dependency on
our infrastructure layer because events
are actually you know on the application
layer it describes the flow of events in
the business but hooking up to a
database doesn't feel right for me
to be used to
to complete a business process maybe you
can use the change data capture to
manipulate your data so for example in
Cosmos TV you can hook up to this event
if you want to maybe copy the data into
a different container so you can change
the partitioning strategy that is more
optimized for a different type of read
so maybe you can use the change data
capture to just you know transform your
data in your database and then save it
again in the same database so it's a lot
of more manipulation within the
infrastructure layer and not the
business
you would certainly use it together you
can certainly use change data capturing
Cosmos DB if you have an Event Source
there and then push that into
um to your event stream let's say to
your uh to Costco or to to Azure event
hub
it can work and you just make sure that
you know what you're doing and what are
the trade-offs
so now
um I guess it's a little I hope it's a
little clearer the the terminologies and
nuances let's take a look at the
different services in Azure that we can
use for particular use cases
so there are a lot it's just if you go
there and say like do event-driven
architecture then you're already
bombarded with a lot of different
options so it's a matter of
understanding again your stories in your
use case and then Weighing on the
trade-offs and and seeing what works
right and again just a reminder that
when you analyze trade-offs
architectural trade-offs don't just
focus on the technology you also have to
focus on your people the ones who are
going to implement this their maturity
level the the developers the Ops that's
going to maintain this infrastructure
the cost of it so it's not just like the
technical features or architectural
features of the services that you need
to focus on
so what are the services for the simple
async request the one we were talking
about earlier where you have a queue
that could do load balancing or load
leveling you can start with the storage
queue it's a cheaper option it has a
very strong SLA and the good thing with
the Azure very simple Azure storage
queue is it actually has a larger
maximum limit for the size of your queue
because it's storage yeah it says files
so it can accommodate 500 to 500
terabytes of worth of messages which is
a lot so if you need to push
large messages you could start with this
but again it's it's a cue so it's pool
style and it can only guarantee at least
once that's another thing we need to
remember like at least once it means
that maybe it persists the message so if
the queue goes down it persisted it
somewhere so it goes up again that
message is still there
but you cannot guarantee that you will
only receive it once you might receive
it twice or twice or I don't know 100
times and your
um your your processor your event
processor needs to be able to have to
handle that that duplication
if you need a little bit more advanced
messaging
um and and yeah with with features like
um ordering or uh
request reply patterns then service bus
is probably
your next choice and it's also full
style but be mindful of the limits on
the amount of data that you can put so
if you're pushing large messages you
might end up
exhausting exhausting the 80 gigabytes
but it can guarantee at least at most
once so that means it has some logic
already to do or algorithm already to do
some you know deduplication supports
that lettering
so you can also subscribe to a dead
letter and do you know your error
handling after that
um
and it also supports you know the
concept of sessions so you can assign a
consumer
or yeah or event consumer event
processor to the same session and every
time you push messages within that same
session let's say again the student
registration flow there could be several
messages related to the same student
which is the same session then from
there you can guarantee the order if you
don't have sessions and you have
competing consumers you cannot guarantee
order in service bus so have to remember
that and then it also supports you know
transactions which is also really really
important so if your consumer is if
you're a producer is pushing data within
the same transaction if one of those
messages fail it can roll back the rest
of the the events or the messages so if
you have that kind of need then service
bus is is your choice
and then we go to like the more pub sub
pattern like the the one I showed you
with um with uh with a choreography
pattern with a broker pattern and the
next you know candidate would be the
event grid so event grid is really
um built for
also push style modification so versus
like the the two other cues or pool
style so that means your consumers need
to be able to know how to connect to
your messaging service
so it has that information whereas if
it's event Grid it's push style then
it's the event grid who knows or
understands how to connect to the
subscriber there's a big difference like
for example you can use event grid to
also push data outside of your
organization as long as you have access
to that let's say in the student
enrollment maybe you need to connect to
some web hook for the government system
and you you have the authentication you
can do that in vent grid but that
government system
couldn't
just listen to your internal service bus
so you have to think about that the and
because it event grid can do this it
also requires that the consumers or the
subscribers have a public IP so that
might be an issue for you if you can't
do that in your network
um it's a serverless it's massively
scalable it can just push I don't know
millions of notifications to a single
consumer per second so you have to make
sure that your consumer can also you
know accommodate that maybe put a
service bus in front of it so that you
can also do load leveling and load
balancing
so for event stream there are also
several services in Azure that you can
use
event Hub and the very popular event
streaming product by which is Apache
Kafka and you can run Apache Kafka on
your own if you have the capability and
you can do the entire operation of your
Kafka clusters in your VMS or containers
or in your in your kubernetes clusters
but you can also use a cloud-based Kafka
which is run by Confluence and of course
you let them manage it you pay them to
do that it's much easier for you and
then you have event Hub event Hub is
very similar to what Kafka can do when
it comes to streaming but it's of course
Azure native supports https and amqp
style messaging you can there's
different tiers and you can read all
about the the different limits in event
Hub but the good thing about event Hub
is that it's like portable to Kafka so
if you have code that talks to Kafka
because you have Kafka running somewhere
else outside Azure you don't have to
change your code to be able to connect
to the event Hub and then you take
advantage of all the service level
agreements from Azure for for event hub
for Event Source we don't really dictate
what you can use to store your events of
course there are some persistence uh
products that built for events but on
the cloud you can use pretty much any
Cloud database in Azure like SQL or your
storage or manage postgres or Cosmos DB
all right so I didn't talk about some of
the integration Services because it's a
little bit too much to deal with but
what I mentioned already that
bigger picture this is all integration
integration point so you have logic apps
Azure durable functions Azure functions
API management to do several things to
be able to pull this all together your
workflow
let's look at let's look a little bit on
on code I have a very simple sample code
just so
um we kind of have an understanding how
this is gonna look like in real and if I
replace all those uh funny diagrams I
showed you earlier with actual uh Azure
Services then you can see that we can
put it all together I'm not saying that
this is the most optimized solution I'm
just using this so that we can
illustrate the point that you can
actually have service bus
managing the the the load for your for
your um for your requests and then you
can publish your events to an event grid
you can have event grid push that data
into other service buses that your other
components like classes and books are
listening to
and then you can save your um
your your state or your events in Cosmos
TV
all right
so this is a very simple implementation
just so we get an idea how this works so
in this code or in this application I
have three different distinct
applications and the goal is that they
don't talk to each other they don't have
reference to each other they don't
invoke each other's API directly because
otherwise if you do that you're
essentially building you know baby
monoliths that's just inside the nursery
and like you know playing and making
chaos so I have three separate apis the
students the classes and the books and I
just wanted to show like how we create
classes or model
um our our commands and our events so
this is the command for when you want to
register your student and you will have
a Handler and in this particular
um sample code I'm also using a library
very familiar with the mediator Library
yeah so that library is a lightweight
library for in-process messaging and it
can help you with all your
command invocation and your event
handler invocation
without all the headaches of dependency
injection so it makes it very easy to
invoke these commands handlers and event
handlers based on the signature of your
commands and events and so it looks
through your assembly and that's the the
magic so I'm using mediator here you can
use other
um libraries I think there's Ian Cooper
He's also talking a lot about event
driven and he's also you know showing
code in in brighter you can also check
that out so the the whole idea is that
you have the command and um and then you
have an event handler inside my event
handler I might do some logic and then
at the end of it I'll publish the the
event called student register and I
would have two handlers for the event
one is writing to the event grid so I
can do my you know publishing to an
integration and then I also have another
Handler
for storing that particular event to my
persistence
so the difference between a command and
a command Handler in an event and event
handler is that command can only have
one Handler so it will only invoke one
Handler but if you do so if you look at
this
uh
code with the mediator so if you invoke
publish it will find all the handlers
that implements that particular
signature for your event so it will
execute it so it's one to one versus one
to many so you can design your
application like that so I have that and
once
once that's done once I called it it
will also automatically enroll the
student in several classes
by writing to event grid and the event
grid pushing to a service bus and then
this classes API is listening to that
service bus again if you're using Azure
functions you can easily do this by
binding your functions because that's
inherently event driven binding your
functions to service bus but in this
case because this is a.net core web API
I used a what you call a hosted service
which is like a background service that
gets started as soon as you start your
application and then it's just open it
will call the service bus all the time
to get a batch of messages and data so
it's very simple
code here to implement I hosted service
so you you have the method for start a
sync which will be invoked when you
start the application and then you also
have to stop a sync when you close the
application and you want to dispose all
your objects but you then you implement
delegates for
processing or so inside let's start I
think you connect to the service bus and
then you create a processor client and
then you implement delegates for
processing the messages and processing
error messages
so if you look at my code it's just
simply with process message I also just
simply triggered the student registered
notification I have some Handler down
the line
okay let me just make sure that this is
running
oops I'm missing an R
so you can see at the start it's already
connecting to my service bus
This Is My Demo service bus so it's
called juicy gossips ignore that
and then I'm just gonna call my my apis
so this is the API for the students so
as soon as I register a student here
that will be executed
so I have my students registered and the
other thing is that remember that I have
two event handlers one is to write to
event grid and the other one is to store
that event so if I want to get all the
events about students then I have that
API student events and you can see this
is how an event look like
so typically you would have a schema for
the event you call the event schema you
would have your event type and schema
version which is also very important
because if you have consumers of your
events they you might want to tell them
how your event would look like and if
you want to change it you might want to
announce it and broadcast it that the
scheme is changing with the new version
and you need to upgrade so that's why
you have the schema version here and
then underneath you have the actual data
which is the full state of the student
and when you change the state of the
student you it will also append a new
event in the store
and so what happens in the class if I go
to class and query that I can see that
there's already one student enrolled
fade which is the same as
this person and then if I add another
one let's say
so if I do that you can see that this
also
there's now a new enrolled students
without calling the API so they don't
have any relationship with each other
it's just all integration within the
events
with a very simple code
so you can get this code um in my GitHub
I'll share that to you later
so
event driven patterns let's get a little
crazy and do something else
no one is crazy enough to to join me
it's almost four o'clock
all right
um what do we do with one of our
projects so now we have just been
talking about Native Azure services but
we can certainly do event driven or be
very creative with the way we Implement
event driven even though we're running
things that don't use native cloud
services or Azure Services you can do it
on our own based on our use case so in
our we're also building a student not
just student a school system a larger
school system for for Denmark and
um
we thought about what if
what if we Implement event driven
end-to-end in full stack from client all
the way to the database because
so far we have just seen
write events commands and then also it's
not asynchronous all the way because at
some point inside your Handler you have
to request something against the
database and then that's not a
synchronous you have to wait for the
database to reply that you have
succeeded in persisting or updating your
data what we wanted to do is to make it
a synchronous all the way to the data
service and we will just receive streams
of results from all the layers and then
push it all the way down to our clients
and that way we will make it very real
time so every time One browser
um loads data and updates it all the
other browsers that's looking at the
same data will also receive it it's you
would say okay it's quite common that's
like you know just using signalr but
this one is with signalr you still have
like a little bit synchronous processing
inside your API since it's calling the
the database but we kind of want to
um experiment a bit
and we're also looking at the different
services that would best
do the job so this is what we came up
with maybe it's familiar for some of you
maybe you have implemented it can you
see it
is it hard to see
okay let me just go through it so at the
bottom you have all the clients so you
have let's say for us we have a web
client and also a mobile client imagine
that there is one student connecting to
the same uh as the same student but
different devices right so those are
different sessions
and from our web client we fire up a
rest we start with the rest request but
that's just to indicate that an event
can happen so we had to indicate I want
to write this it's a request but I'm not
expecting a result it's a command please
write this and at the same time our
reads are also events we fire up an
event say I have subscribed to a list of
students so let's say I from the client
I want please create a student or please
register a student and let me subscribe
to the list of students at the same time
so we're not getting any results yet
we're just uh firing that up and then
there's we have two separate apis so we
have a couple of apis for doing rights
and we have one API that's doing query
and both of them are responsible for all
this event that were fired by the client
to maintain a state of that so the
subscribers so we have in our query
layer and our API layer sort of a cached
or a state of all the subscribers so we
know how to get back to them later on we
know how to inform them once the
processing has completed
and then before we reach the database we
have a data service where we have a
websocket connection
so in within the websocket we just say I
want to write this to the database but
I'm not going to wait for the reply just
inform you when it's done when your
database operation is done and that's
the same with our query I need the list
of students but I'm not going to wait
for reply then you know with this
pattern because it's totally
asynchronous they're all independent you
can pretty much be very flexible and
scalable
so the data service talks to the
database and in this case we're actually
implement we used we chose to use a
database called xtdb anyone familiar
so xtdb is its base enclosure
and it's a unbundled
by temporal database it runs in a
container so we can run it on the cloud
and when I say by temporal then it's by
default inherently it saves two types of
data and an event driven application
time is very important attribute and in
this database by default it's very
optimized to to save to or look or query
or index two time dimensions that's why
it's by temporal transaction time and
value time you have a lot of temporal
databases dynamodb is temporal you save
transaction time you can go back in time
but for xddb you can go back in time in
different dimensions one is the
transaction time when the event was
committed and the other one went the
event is actually supposed to be valid
so for example use register your student
and that student is registered today but
it's actually the registration is only
valid next month so the xtdb is very
good at indexing that so that you can
query what is really happening and when
it really happened
um and the other thing with xcdb is it's
unbundled so to be able to execute that
that sort of because it can also be very
uh scalable so it has clients or nodes
to be able to do that it also uses the
concept of event streams or immutable
logs of database transactions and to
make it more powerful you can use Kafka
so you can choose whatever
storage
there is that you can use to log
transactions and to actually save the
document the attribute so you have the
document database or the document
storage and the transaction storage and
you can choose from the plethora of data
Platforms in cloud or hybrid what to use
so the core xcdb is just very
lightweight so we use that it's closure
based it's kind of smart sometimes I get
confused what it's doing because I don't
write closure my my colleagues do so our
data service is also running closure
it's in a container so it still runs in
the cloud we can put that in Azure app
container service
that is that right yeah no Azure
container apps here I'm getting confused
Azure container app so that we can make
it scalable but once the processing is
done in the data services pushes back to
the query that has all the um all the uh
again the states of all the
subscriptions or ongoing subscription
and it will only update let's say you
subscribe to list of students then it
will update that cache the data service
will via the websocket and the query
service pushes down to all the clients
so if you have 10 000 students listening
to get students they will all be updated
and they don't have to refresh a page
let's look a little bit very quickly on
our test
UI for that
um
so we have a UI that could illustrate
what's happening with our data
um so if I hear this and we connect so I
have two browsers two different sessions
and like I said every single
transactions you do whether it's a
reader right it's an event so these are
a list of our events and each of these
events have schema so I can have an
event called query by students by a
school
schools by sorry students
by school attribute and if I say ngg
here
so I get a list of all the data here and
that's just live yeah and then from the
other browser I can do the same I can
subscribe to students
by
School attribute
ngg
and you can see very fast that if I try
to change one student here
let me find you sir Siri two here so if
I change this person's name to Mary lug
and update that you can see this also
updated in the same session
using this Paradigm everything is event
driven
all right
I have a few minutes left
so just go through
again when you start implementing event
driven or you're in the middle of it
there are so many things that we need to
consider event schema I have mentioned
that having a kind of a central
repository of all your events if you're
working in a big Enterprise would be
helpful so that you can publish the
catalogs for example the Azure in Azure
you have GitHub repository for all their
schemas for all the events that they
fire from their infrastructure
and you can use autorest to be able to
Auto generate because they use open API
they can use autores to Auto generate
some of this as you know into into code
effectively once exactly once all these
how many times the indempotence of your
applications or your API and consumers
ordering if you need that is very
important in your design how do you
handle error in a distributed system how
do you trace all the events using a
correlation ID for all the related
events and very important security and
privacy now that we're dealing with data
that resides everywhere data in transit
all the time so now we start talking
about you know privacy how do we can we
actually delete data from an immutable
database or invent log so you know
things we need to talk about to think
about we learned a lot different
patterns what can we use that we can
actually also be very creative and do
full stack event driven using Open
Source xddb by the ways open source but
if you want to learn more I'm going to
share the links I want to you know also
recommend two books that I really like
designing data intensive application by
Martin clepman and fundamentals of
software architecture by Mark Richards
and Neil Ford and I'm going to share my
GitHub account that second one there the
designing data intensive application
made me cry I didn't know that it books
can make you cry who does that
thank you so much NDC please reach out
on Twitter at marilog and that's me at
some Hotel doing my star jump
thank you
[Applause]